[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL BASILYAN: So the talk
is called Research Workloads
on Preemptible VMs.
I'm Michael Basilyan,
product manager at Google.
I'm joined by two friends from
Two Sigma, Chris and Rodrigo.
They'll give a little bit
more of an introduction
in the second half when they
talk about their workloads
on preemptible VMs.
So here's the outline.
I'm going to talk
for a few minutes
about what preemptible VMs
are, and how they work,
and what the general concept is.
And then the Two Sigma
guys will tell their story.
Cool.
All right.
So if I had to tell you what a
preemptible VM is in one slide,
and if there's one
thing that you remember
from my half of the talk,
is that a preemptible VM
is a regular VM, like
any other VM that you
can get on Compute Engine.
There's just two caveats.
One is that it cannot run
for more than 24 hours.
We limit the lifetime and the
uptime of the VM for 24 hours.
And the other is that we reserve
the right to take them away
with 30 seconds of
notice at any point.
It's right there in the name.
That's what makes
it preemptible.
The upside of it is that they
only cost $0.01 per core hour.
And that includes
Intel Skylakes.
That's up to 80% cheaper
than a regular GCE VM.
If you attach a GPU to
that preemptible VM,
it'll be about 70% cheaper
than a regular GPU.
If you attach a local SSD
to that preemptible VM,
it'll be around 40% cheaper
than a local SSD attached
to a standard VM.
And local SSD, you
might have heard already
at some point today or in
one of the earlier talks,
are high performance attached
storage for virtual machines.
The other highlight is
that prices are constant.
There's no bidding of any kind.
This is the price.
What you see is what you
get in terms of price.
That doesn't change.
Cool.
So what can you do
with compute that's
just sort of
randomly disappearing
with 30 seconds of notice?
There's actually
quite a few things
that we've seen people do.
Really anything that's
embarrassingly parallel,
or pleasantly parallel
as some people say,
anything that is high
throughput, or is composed
of a lot of
independent tasks that
can be solved independently
where losing a single machine
doesn't mean that
everything else disappears,
or if you can figure
out how to capture state
for your computations.
So Monte Carlo
simulations, where
different machines are solving
different input conditions.
Image understanding-- rendering,
immediate transcoding, anything
really to do with images.
If you imagine a use case
where you have 1,000 images,
and you want to
assign each of those
to one of 100
preemptible VMs to do
some processing on that
image, if that VM goes away
because it gets preempted,
you don't really lose anything
except for that image.
And you can reschedule
that work if your scheduler
knows how to handle that.
And I'll talk about
that in a little bit.
Data analysis, of course--
our Dataproc product
supports preemptible VMs.
Genomics and health
workloads-- if you
search the web for Broad
Institute preemptible VMs,
you'll see a write
up of their use case.
Financial analysis, of
course-- and you'll hear more
about that in the second half.
And many, many others,
including physics, math,
chemistry, and so on.
And to be clear,
people are using these
to solve very real workloads.
So on any given day we have
10,000 to 50,000 core clusters
of preemptible VMs being
used, multiple ones.
And the largest we've ever
seen is an MIT math professor
doing some research in a
weekend on 580,000 cores.
So this was around
200 to 300 core years
of compute in a weekend.
OK.
Using them is relatively
straightforward and easy.
There's just one flag
that you have to do.
Like I said, they are
like regular GCVMs.
You configure them
like a regular GCVM.
All you do is add a
dash, dash preemptible
to your command line.
Or in the UI, you just
select preemptibility on.
Or in the API, you select
preemptibility to be true.
Generally, of
course, you're going
to be creating more than
one of these things.
And so that's where things get
a little bit more interesting.
But fortunately, there's a lot
of tools that make it easy.
We have our GCE managed
instance groups that
can help you manage
instances of preemptible VMs,
and recreate them once
they get preempted.
We have a published
solution on our website
for how to use HTCondor,
which is a very popular job
scheduling tool with
preemptible VMs.
Kubernetes and GKE, of course,
support preemptible VMs.
And in the second half,
you'll hear more about Two
Sigma's Cook job scheduler that
supports preemptible VMs as
well.
So I wanted to give you guys
some best practices for how
to use preemptible VMs
to make the most of them,
and to minimize the preemptions.
So like old school
telephone companies,
nights and weekends are best.
Obviously you want
to avoid times
when the data centers are busy.
You want to architect your
system for regular preemption.
You should expect that
preemptions will happen.
They're not a one-off
rare situation.
We see on historical rates,
5% to 15% preemption rates.
You should know that this will
change as a function of the VMs
that you build, the zones
you use, and time of day.
And of course, you
should be prepared
to move regions and zones
if preemption rates get
really high in a place.
But that's good cloud
practice anyway.
Beyond that, use shutdown
scripts and checkpoints
to save state if that's
appropriate for your workload.
I'm talking about standard
GCE shutdown scripts
that are just part of Linux.
The smaller and
less choosy the VM,
the less likely it
is to be preempted.
So a 64 core preemptible
VM with local SSD and GPU
is much more likely to
be in somebody's way
than a 16 core preemptible VM.
On the website we also have
a bunch of best practices
that outline a lot of this
with a lot more detail
than you can read.
Cool.
And I'm going to turn it
over to the Two Sigma team.
CHRIS FORTIER: Good
morning, everyone.
I'm Chris Fortier
with Two Sigma.
So I'll talk a bit about
our research workloads
on preemptible VMs.
So a quick disclaimer.
Even though we're in a
technology conference,
most of us are technologists,
we work at a financial firm.
So we are not here to talk
about selling or solicitation
of securities or instruments.
We are not giving you any
stock advice, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
Really just talk about
our technology story.
So who are we?
So I'm Chris.
I was formerly the head of
private cloud engineering
at Two Sigma.
Currently the head of
public cloud engineering.
A lot of that work
really is figuring out,
how do we adopt cloud
computing and bring it
into our company, especially
the native services, which
are really interesting for us.
In a few minutes you'll
hear from Rodrigo.
Also works on my team.
He spends a lot of our time
figuring out our distributed
compute environment using GCP.
A lot of it is on
preemptible virtual machines.
So on our section
of the agenda, we're
going to talk a little bit
about batched research,
and what that means to
us, and how we do it.
A little history of
our distributed compute
environment.
We'll give you a taste of
what it looks like today.
A bit about how we
build platforms on GCP.
And then some of the
challenges and takeaways,
which is kind of the interesting
things for most people.
So batch research process.
Two Sigma's a quant hedge fund.
And so how does a
quant hedge fund
make money and
survive in the world?
You may envision as a model or
that comes up with this idea,
oh, eureka.
Here's how we're
going to make money.
Draws a technique on a
whiteboard, and, poof,
it becomes production.
Because that's how it
works in the movies, right?
So not exactly.
The modeling workflow
actually looks
fairly similar to a
typical developer workflow.
There's an idea of
what they want to do.
They do some work with it.
They do some data analysis
and shifting of data
to figure out what makes sense.
And they try to write
some techniques out.
And then they want to simulate
it, usually research back
testing in the market.
Like, hey, how would this
have performed over the past n
number of years?
And then from there, once
they actually figure out,
hey, this is going to
actually work for us,
they do a typical
review process.
Similar to a code review,
they write papers up.
They present to their peers.
They figure it out.
And it becomes a production
product at some point.
A lot of what we
use Google Cloud for
is that technique in data
in the simulation area.
A lot of the data
analysis tools,
a lot of the simulation
back testing,
we're running on Google today.
And especially the
simulation of preemptible VMs
is where GCE really
shines for us.
So a bit about our
distributed compute
environment, and kind
of over the history
over the past 15 or 16 years.
As legend has it, when
Two Sigma was founded,
a couple of founders, a couple
of early employees time share
compute based on a whiteboard.
Literally just on a white board,
hey, Bob has it this week.
Susie has it next
week, et cetera.
And I guess that worked for a
few years, at least three years
or so, from what I'm told.
Early 2004 the team decided to
work on an internal scheduling
system.
Really just we want
to be technologists.
We want to figure out a better
system than a white board,
quite frankly.
So that worked
well for apparently
eight years or so,
the internal one.
And around 2012, Mesos
came on the scene
and really captured
our attention.
It solved a lot of the really
interesting lower level
problems.
How do you do
resource management?
How do you do scheduling?
Those are the types of
things, like how do you
execute a job on this
host, aren't something
that are a core competency of
what Two Sigma wanted to be
or wants to be.
So we really adopted Mesos
full speed with that.
But we still want to maintain
its fair share of scheduling
things.
So even back in the early days
of a whiteboard, we're like,
hey, we want
efficient utilization.
We want it shared
across everyone.
So we decided to
write what is now
known as the Cook
framework, which
is a framework for fair share
scheduling of jobs on Mesos.
And we've been using that
ever since 2012 when we first
started writing it.
So 2016, cloud
computing two years ago
was definitely a
mainstream concept.
We decided we really wanted
to start working with that,
and figuring out, how do
we use elastic capacity?
Up to that point, we'd always
had physical data centers.
Everything is,
here's the hardware
and here's what we can use.
So we started making
a lot of changes
to connect our data
centers to the cloud,
and then changes
to Cook and Mesos
to work in these environments.
And then now, mid-2018, we have
real dynamic cloud compute,
which has really been
very beneficial for us,
to be able to say,
what is our workload?
What can we do?
We're not limiting
our modelers based
on the compute that we
can get to them anymore.
But there's a caveat
though that we're going
to talk about in a minute.
Even though we have a
classic dynamic compute,
we don't have dynamic storage,
or networking, or other things
still.
We'll talk about in a few
minutes about how we're still
running hybrid cloud with
Google and other data centers.
There we go.
So a little bit of capacity
over time, which kind of just
symbolizes what I just
mentioned, where over time is
a very step function.
On this date we decided to
order a whole bunch of servers
and put in a data center.
And that's how it lasted
for 15 years or so.
And mid-2016, you start to
see a lot of dynamic spikes
based on user workload.
This is really when
cloud computing
became a thing for us.
So one, it opened up compute
ability for our modelers,
but also proved a theory
that we had years before,
which is that our
demand isn't linear.
It's not, oh, here's what
we're going to use today.
It's a lot more
opportunistic based
on what phase of
research somebody is in.
And then there's that.
So that's a bit of the history.
That's about how
we got to today.
But what are our users?
So Rodrigo and I,
we work on what's
called platform engineering.
So we deal with a lot
of the lower level,
how do you build a system?
How do you get resources
available to somebody?
And there are teams above us.
So we think of
modeling engineering,
which the next step above
us, they use our platform
as a building block.
Modeling engineering
does a lot of stuff
to work with techniques,
with data analysis,
a lot of like how
to run a simulation.
Then above them we have
quantitative engineers.
Quantitative engineers,
they work a lot closer
to the modelers.
And they work with actually
writing the models,
actually writing
techniques, writing tactics,
writing the actual code that
will eventually do trading.
And then finally,
we have modelers,
who are our researchers
that are going through,
trying to find information
that is tradable
and actually usable.
So we have a bit
of a description
of kind of the workloads.
And this is where fair
share scheduling actually
comes back to us and
is kind of important,
is that even though we have
all the dynamic compute,
I mentioned we don't
have dynamic storage.
We don't have dynamic
networking yet.
So we still want to
be able to fair share
our resources with people.
And we also still care
about things like quotas.
We still care what the bill
looks like every month.
We care about a lot of
those types of things.
So when you think of the
workloads that we're running,
again, modeling engineers
who are building just
right above us, they're doing
scheduling, Cook schedulers.
They're doing other things.
They need a little bit of
capacity, a few hundred
gigabytes, 10s, 20s of vCPUs
to test out their work.
The quantitative engineers,
though, because they're
working closer to models,
they actually want to test,
hey, does this
model actually work?
From a technical
standpoint, they need more.
They need to do more testing.
And then our modelers,
there are probably
an infinite number of
data sources and things
to trade on in the world.
And our modelers want
to run every single one
of those, which, of
course, isn't possible.
So they are the highest demand
of usage across our company.
Which actually
these slides all are
showing that, kind of what we
see from our internal usage
patterns.
And on that note, I'll
throw it over to Rodrigo
to talk about how we actually
build platforms in GCP.
RODRIGO MANYARI:
Thank you, Chris.
So Chris just talked about
kind of how the environment has
evolved over time,
and also capacity,
how it used to be this
very nice step function.
And in recent years
it's more like bursting.
And also how we kind
of view our users,
how they share this platform.
And we can think about all
of this as very cool data.
And we can do some more
analysis, and dig into it.
Or we can take that
as requirements,
which is what I think we've been
doing for the last two years.
So when you think
about this environment,
we really have two requirements.
One, following the assumption
that demand is very bursty,
we need to be able to scale
up and down automatically.
And two, everyone is
sharing this platform,
but everyone has
different needs.
So we're not in a position
where we kind of impose
people what resources they get.
We want this cluster
to be driven by demand.
And as we started to move
these workloads to the cloud,
we kind of came up with
two guiding principles.
The first thing that I want
to talk about is security.
We take security very
seriously at Two Sigma.
As you can imagine,
this environment
is one of the most
sensitive ones,
because it has some good
stuff going in there.
So we stick to GCE and some
core networking products,
like interconnects, to provide
connectivity back and forth
between Two Sigma and GCP.
I'm not going to talk more about
security in this presentation,
because other guys, Nick
and Michael from Two Sigma,
are giving enough
talks on the topic.
The next thing that
I want to talk about,
though, is kind
of the other thing
that we always try
very hard to keep
in mind, which is elasticity,
add value to the users,
add value to the business, and
do so in a cost effective way.
Because we've been
operating data centers
for 10 to 15 years,
we know how much
it costs to run
these environments.
And we cannot just go to the
cloud and start spending money
like crazy because it's
this shiny new thing,
or because everyone is doing it.
We have to be able
to add real value.
And we need to be able to do
that in a cost effective way.
Now, preemptible VMs
and custom machine types
is what really
allows us to do that.
We get the 80% flat discount.
And then with custom
machine types,
we create exactly the
resources that Cook needs--
I'm going to talk
more about Cook--
but that Cook needs to
schedule these jobs.
Now, this is a fairly
large environment.
And I don't want to be on the
hook, creating and deleting VMs
all the time.
And Chris, I'm sure,
doesn't want me
to be on the hook to do that.
So we need an autoscaler, which
is a product that we've been
working on since early 2016.
So now, if you take
the autoscaler,
you take preemptible VMs, and
you take custom machine types,
now you get all
the building blocks
to build this platform
where you can scale
to a couple of Two Sigma data
center sizes for, let's say,
a single user.
Before 2016, they had to
share all this platform
between each other.
Now, it's just a matter of
putting stuff in some queue.
And then you're going to
get capacity eventually.
But before talking
about autoscaling,
I want to talk about
Cook a little bit.
Because Cook sits at
the top of the stack.
And without Cook, there
really isn't much.
What are these VMs good for
if nothing is running on them?
So Cook is a Mesos framework.
Early versions were
developed back in 2012.
It's open source.
And it has this very core
concept of fair scheduling
that we use both on-prem
and in the cloud,
but just for different reasons.
Fair scheduling
essentially just guarantees
that no one user takes over
an entire cluster, which
is super important when
you're running on-prem.
But let me give you
an example I think
that's going to be a
lot easier to understand
than just me talking about it.
So suppose user red here has
been running overnight a bunch
of jobs, and he got lucky.
He got the entire cluster.
But it's 7:00, 8:00
AM New York time.
And now we have like three
modelers that want to run jobs.
There is one kind of
obvious problem here.
There is no capacity to run
all these additional jobs.
But there is another problem.
Let's say we make up
some capacity somehow.
Now we need a way to
determine who goes first.
And we can do some
kind of round robin.
We can do first
come, first serve.
We can do random.
Or we can do kind of
fair sharing, which
is what Cook does.
So essentially it's going
to take this virtual queue.
So each one of these
three virtual queues,
it's going to merge them
into one global queue.
And then it's going to
order them by fairness.
And fairness here
means it's going
to look at, what's your current
usage, what's your backlog.
And then based on
that, it's going
to determine some
kind of ordering.
Then in the background, it's
going to preempt some red jobs.
And then it's going to
schedule everything else.
There is a downside to
this kind of situation,
which is we lost
some computation
time that we've already done.
But it's not a big deal.
And I think it's much,
much better than just
making people wait.
Eventually those jobs are going
to get put back in the queue.
Now, you might be thinking,
we're at a cloud conference.
Why don't you just create
more VMs and be done with it?
You don't need to
preempt anyone.
Which is kind of fair.
And it kind of works in theory.
We are less constrained
with capacity.
We have access to
more machine types.
But now by having
this elastic cluster,
we created the
problem for ourselves.
Now we have this
ramp up latency.
So suppose there's like, I don't
know, 10,000 jobs in the queue.
And somehow we magically
decided we need 1,000 VMs.
If I send 1,000 requests
to GCP, well, first of all,
there was API rate limitings.
So I cannot just fire 1,000
requests all at the same time.
And then there is no
guarantee that I'm going
to get the 1,000 VMs right now.
And even if I could get
them right now, remember,
we work in a very
secure environment.
These VMs need to
get an identity.
They need to register to
other security services.
They need to register to Mesos.
And then Cook eventually
needs to schedule these jobs.
So all of these steps, they take
time, a couple minutes here,
a couple minutes there.
And then when you
add up everything,
it's time that is
non-negligible.
And the user can
actually feel it.
So we want to avoid that.
And Cook and fair sharing
is kind of the thing
that we use to
solve this problem.
It allows us to share
resources as they come up,
and as they become available.
So now that we
talked about Cook,
we can start talking
about autoscaling,
because Cook and the
autoscaler work together.
And it's kind of the next
logical step in this thing.
So I think I
mentioned this before.
The first version
we wrote in 2016.
One of the reasons why
we wrote the autoscaler
is because we wanted to
have a deep integration
with the rest of the
Two Sigma ecosystem,
in particular Cook and Mesos.
And then we also wanted
to take the opportunity
to give Cook the right resources
by creating the right machine
types.
Over time as we
[INAUDIBLE] on Launchy,
we've started to use more,
and more, and more custom
machine types.
And now we're at a point where
we almost exclusively use
custom machine types.
And then the other thing is,
as the usage of the cloud grew,
as we started to move more and
more workloads into the cloud,
we had to expand to
multiple regions.
And we had to expand
to multiple zones
to try to avoid preemption.
And we had to write some code
here and there into Launchy
to be able to kind of
chase this capacity.
Because you can have a pretty
large cluster in one zone.
And then you could
lose some percentage.
But you still have the jobs.
So you need to run
those jobs somewhere.
And Launchy and
Cook together, they
allow us to do these
types of things.
A high level overview of Launchy
is essentially a big loop.
The first thing that
we're going to do
is check for idle
or unhealthy VMs.
This is essentially
scaling down.
If the VMs are idle,
just scale down.
Then we're going to look
at the job queue in Cook.
If there's something,
we keep it in memory.
Otherwise, we just stop scaling.
Then we check for
what we call limits.
Limits here could be GCP quotas.
It could be internal
limits, like don't
spend more than X amount
of money per hour.
Don't create more than X number
of VMs on a given time window.
Because, remember, they have
to talk to internal services.
These services are kind of set
up for some maximum peak load.
So we cannot just
start hammering them.
If all the checks are good, if
all the checks and balances are
good, then we compute what we
call a runnable subset of jobs.
That essentially is,
look at the job queue.
Let's say I'm a user, and I
have a quota of 1,000 jobs.
And I already have
500 jobs running.
If I put 2,000 more
jobs on the queue,
obviously only 500 are
going to get scheduled.
So we don't want to create
resources for 2,000 jobs.
We only want to create
resources for 500 jobs.
So that's what the
runnable subset means.
Now that we have
the requirements,
we can actually go and
compute the machine types
that we want to use.
The input of this
function is essentially
just the list of requirements.
And the output is almost a
fully well-formed payload
that we can send to Google.
So it's something like,
create 200 VMs of type X,
and another 150 of type Y,
and something like that.
And then the last thing,
to kind of wrap it up,
we need to know where
to put these VMs.
So the last step
in the scaling loop
is figuring out where
to create these VMs.
We have the payloads already.
And we send a request to Google.
Hopefully we get
everything that we wanted.
And then we write
some more metrics
to do further analysis offline.
Or we're going to use
these metrics also
in the distribution
calculation in the next loops.
So if you put Cook
and Launchy together,
this is pretty
much what you get.
This is an intraday
graph of capacity.
In Two Sigma teal you
have the used resources.
And I don't know if
you can see it here,
but there is a little
spike in green,
which is provisioned resources.
So there's usually
a little discrepancy
between what we create and
what's actually being used,
which is not a big deal.
I think we're OK
living with that.
But I think the more interesting
things here is kind of the fact
that this graph
clearly is very spiky.
And the spikes are
very short lived.
So this data validates
our initial assumption
that demand is very bursty,
and that we just should not
have these kind of fixed
blocks of resources, business
hours New York, or 24/7,
or something like that.
Now, what's more annoying
about this is the fact
that things like what's
your average cluster size
doesn't really make sense here.
I can give you a global max
over the last six months,
and some kind of
local max interweek,
or something like that.
But average utilization
or average size
doesn't really make much sense.
And beyond the technicality
that I cannot give a straight
number, this is important
because all these resources
talk back to services
in Two Sigma.
And people have to
do capacity planning.
They need to know if their
service is going to have
10 replicas or 20 replicas.
And it creates these frictions.
Because on the cloud
we're doing these things
where we want to scale
up as much as possible.
But internally, people
have limited resources,
and they need to be
aware of these things.
So let's talk about allocation.
So if we recap, we've
talked about elasticity.
We've talked about how
we can scale up and down,
and give these
resources to our users.
But we also need to do it
in a cost effective way.
And allocation is just
one metric for this.
Usually it hovers
between 90% to 95%.
And we can achieve this
with Launchy and Cook.
But there are these dips.
Every once in a
while there are dips.
And you might be thinking,
what's the deal with that?
Like these guys
wrote an autoscaler,
and they wrote a
scheduler, and they still
have these pretty
bad inefficiencies.
But they are explainable.
And it's really
because the one thing
that we try to optimize for
is to never have a backlog.
We moved to the cloud.
And we don't want
to be in a situation
where someone has to
wait for resources.
So granted, we have some
kind of restrictions
in how fast we scale up.
But we tried to
push that boundary
as far as possible to kind of
provide a good user experience.
So let me give you
an example of how you
can end up in this situation.
Suppose that T0,
nothing is happening.
A couple of jobs
running on a single VM.
We're at 100% allocation.
Say at T1 a user
comes, and they want
to run a couple of workloads
or a couple of jobs.
Now we have a backlog.
And this is exactly
the situation
that we want to avoid.
So Cook and Launchy
start doing their thing.
They create some VMs.
They bootstrap.
They register to Mesos.
And Cook schedules that.
And now the user
is fully running.
We drop to 90% allocation.
For whatever reason, there
was a little inefficiency.
Not such a big deal.
But this is when it
gets interesting.
Let's say half a day goes
by, and now we're at T50.
Most of the job's finished.
But there is still one
job in every single VM.
And obviously, we cannot
terminate this VM,
because we don't want to waste
this progress that we've made.
So we keep them alive.
And this is when
you see the dips.
allocation drops to 25%.
But there is like a
twist to this example.
Let's say really most
of the jobs finish.
We terminate the VMs
that were fully idle.
But there is still one
VM with one job running.
And we're still
at 25% allocation.
All right.
So what actually happened here?
What we found out over
time is that just looking
at this percentage at face value
doesn't really make much sense.
And it doesn't give
us the full picture.
It's not the same
thing saying we
wasted 75% of a 100,000 cores
cluster than saying we wasted
75% of a 500 cores cluster.
And we'd rather look at the
CPU hour and memory hour rates
that we paid for but
we didn't actually use,
rather than just
looking at this number.
But more importantly,
I think is the fact
that you have to keep in
mind that we want to avoid
having a backlog at any time.
We don't want people just
waiting for resources.
So this allocation thing is
the second kind of priority.
We optimize for it, but we
don't try to look good on paper
over users having
a good experience.
And this is just one
of the many challenges
that we have on a
daily basis and that we
have to deal with in
this elastic environment.
But there's many, many more that
Chris is going to talk about.
CHRIS FORTIER: Hello again.
So we only have a
few minutes left.
We know that we
are the last thing
standing between you and lunch.
So we'll try to get through
these fairly straightforward.
So we talked about a lot
of the interesting things
and the problems we've solved,
been our big challenges so far,
and what we have left to solve.
A lot of it does stem
from being hybrid cloud,
and that we're using
dynamic compute in Google,
but all of our data stores
are still on-prem somewhere.
They're still a SQL server.
They're still an
[INAUDIBLE] cluster.
And getting all that
data from our data center
into Google to do any
computation is a challenge.
And we're still working
through the right way
to solve that one.
Especially with back
pressure as well.
So the ability to spin
up a 5X data center
is great for our users.
They love that ability.
Our network team, our
infrastructure teams,
they don't love us
when we do that.
They tend to get very upset when
we DDoS their services because
of our users.
So solving those types of
things, solving QoS and network
fair share is something that
we haven't even looked at yet.
So those are some of the things
to really solve and figure out.
As Michael mentioned,
checkpoint and restore.
So we talked about 15 years
of history of Two Sigma of how
we've done research.
Some of the stuff
that was built 10,
12 years ago, we're
still running.
And it doesn't necessarily
support checkpointing.
It doesn't support restoring.
So in those types of
use cases, there's
stuff we can do from
the engineering side.
But there's also
stuff we go talk
to our users to figure out,
can their system handle it?
Can they go rewrite
and add a feature
to checkpoint to
somewhere, and then
figure out how to make
their life more dynamic?
So some of the takeaways.
To get through those, we are
able to do a lot of things
now that we couldn't do before.
Like I said, the ability to spin
up data centers despite an API
call, the optionality of it.
What's the ability for me to
land a TPU in a data center?
None.
It's not possible.
But with Google, I can
just make it an API call.
Oh, add a TPU here.
Add 50 GPUs over here.
It's something that our modelers
are really, really looking for,
and it opens up a ton of
research possibilities
for them.
Our investments in things
like Cook and our autoscaler
have really paid off and
opened a bunch of value.
But then the takeaway
is also, hybrid cloud
introduces a lot of frictions,
which a lot of people
have talked about in trying
to operate both environments.
There's many unsolved problems.
And then improving scheduling
is a never ending quest.
A lot of the optionality, custom
instance types, for example,
isn't something that
we had two years ago.
So the idea to go
through and say, oh,
I want X number of
CPU, X number of RAM
is a really interesting feature.
But every time these come
out is another optimization
that we can make
in our environment.
The obligatory-- we are hiring
across the platform engineering
teams, our cloud security
teams, and even some of our data
teams.
The teams that
are actually using
some of these services really
hardcore are also hiring.
We have lots of openings.
The slide earlier-- there
are about nine talks by Two
Sigma this week.
Feel free to check out
some of the other ones.
Some of them are
more PE focused.
Some of them are more
security focused.
Some of them are
more data focused.
So we recommend going
to see some of those.
And then last but
not least, thank you.
I think we have about
five minutes left for Q&A.
[MUSIC PLAYING]